KATE: But he is a lot of things.
He's an author.
He's a motivational speaker.
He's a musician.
And he actually founded
a nonprofit called--
is it "Re-rowt" Or 'Re-root"?
SAULPAUL: "Rowt."
KATE: ReRoute.
So he has a special performance
and talk for us today.
He's going to tell us a little
bit about his background, where
he came from.
He's got a very
interesting story.
And also, he's
going to jam for us.
So get ready.
Here we go.
Thank you for coming.
SaulPaul.
[APPLAUSE]
SAULPAUL: All right.
Y'all ready to have some fun
for the next 15, 20 minutes?
[CHEERING]
All right.
All right, that's what's up.
So my name is SaulPaul,
S-A-U-L-P-A-U-L, Saul Paul.
Not Sean Paul.
That's a Jamaican dude.
Not "South Park,"
that's a cartoon.
Not Sao Paulo, but SaulPaul.
Cool.
And I'm a rapper.
That's what I do.
I also play this guitar.
[STATIC]
Oh.
I'm telling you.
No bueno.
But I have to use it.
I like handheld mikes.
I know it's terrible, right?
All right.
So I'm going to start
off with a song.
I'm going to start
with with-- yeah,
can I get your help
on this one, Kate?
KATE: Sure.
SAULPAUL: All right.
Cool.
So check this out.
We're going to make
a song together.
It'll be cool.
So I need a couple volunteers.
You don't have to come up,
and you don't have to dance.
You just have to
give me a word, so
like-- you're the closest to me.
I'm going to start with you.
Like any word.
AUDIENCE: Apple.
SAULPAUL: Apple.
I love it.
The first thing that popped
into my head was fruit.
What's the first thing
that popped into your head?
KATE: Yeah, competitor.
SAULPAUL: Yeah, I know.
I was like, why'd
everybody laugh?
And I was like, oh,
that's why, that's why.
OK, I get it, I get it.
OK, how about you, ma'am,
because I like pink.
AUDIENCE: Wednesday.
SAULPAUL: Wednesday.
OK, wow.
It's Google.
I expected more creativity.
All right, all right.
This is so crazy.
Every time I see you
all eating salad,
I think you're
eating Froot Loops.
I don't know why.
Might be the cherries.
I don't know what it is.
If it was me, I'd be
eating Froot Loops.
OK, who else?
How about you, ma'am?
AUDIENCE: Sky.
SAULPAUL: Sky.
All right.
How about this?
Somebody give me a
big word, like a word
that Kate probably
can't even spell right
without spell check.
AUDIENCE: Entrepreneurialship.
SAULPAUL: Wow, wow.
Thank you.
She did that with
swag, like, really?
Like, really?
OK.
How about-- uh-oh.
KATE: He said it wrong.
That's not my fault.
SAULPAUL: How about you, sir?
KATE: I'm just the--
AUDIENCE: I was
going to say taco.
SAULPAUL: Taco for
the-- All right.
Taco.
All right.
Let me see.
Who else?
Who wants to volunteer a word?
AUDIENCE: Salad.
SAULPAUL: Salad?
All right.
AUDIENCE: Do you need a verb?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAULPAUL: I know, right?
No more lunch shows.
You said, do I need a verb?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SAULPAUL: Yeah, like Mad Libs?
OK.
Who else?
How about you, sir?
AUDIENCE: Sprint.
SAULPAUL: Sprint.
Like the phone company or like--
AUDIENCE: Running.
SAULPAUL: --jogging?
OK, running.
OK, we got sprint.
All right.
How about you, ma'am?
Just know, if you
look uncomfortable,
I'm probably picking you next.
So every-- yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: Happy.
SAULPAUL: Happy.
All right.
That's a good word.
And the biggest
word, I need one--
like what's the biggest
word anybody could think of?
Like multisyllabic, like
just biggest word anybody
can think of.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAULPAUL: Wait,
what did you say?
AUDIENCE:
Antidisestablishmentarianism.
SAULPAUL: Yeah.
And what did you say?
AUDIENCE:
Supercalifragilisticexpialidocious.
AUDIENCE: That's
not a real word.
SAULPAUL: Wow.
Kate is the woman.
KATE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAULPAUL: I love it.
OK.
All right, so check it out.
This is kind of connected to
the story I'm going to tell you,
all right?
I'm going to tell you a
story about how I graduated
from the prestigious University
of Texas at Austin with a 4.0.
[APPLAUSE]
But it was after I was
locked up in the Texas State
Penitentiary, convicted
of four felonies.
So that's why do what I do.
I recognize I have
a unique story,
and I believe I have
a special purpose.
And I just have to do it,
and I do it through my music.
And so I'll share
a story about that.
But something I
figured out in life
is that you don't get to
pick your circumstances.
It is what it is, right?
So you just don't get to
pick your circumstances.
Kind of like when you're
at work sometimes.
You get a project that's
not fair, but they're like,
here's the deadline.
Make it happen.
Just gotta do what you gotta do.
It's like all throughout life.
This is what I figured out.
So with this song, I didn't
get to pick these words.
But I'm going to make
up a song, and I'm
going to incorporate all
these words into my song.
All right.
So we're going to do
this together, right?
I did this one time.
I did it on "America's
Got Talent."
It was pretty cool.
They invited me out.
I did the deal.
Mariah Carey's husband,
know who that is?
AUDIENCE: Nick Cannon.
SAULPAUL: Nick Cannon,
all right, all right.
Nick Cannon was
there, and he was
like-- but I don't
have Nick Cannon today.
Today, I have the lovely Kate.
All right.
So when I was on
"America's Got Talent,"
I had these big poster
boards, and so I
would get a word
from the judges.
I'd get a word from the crowd.
And then they would write it,
and then I did what I did.
So then we put it on the screen.
We got it up there.
Two things I need you to do.
We're going to
make up some music.
Let me put this together.
You can't have a
song without music.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is create some music.
Do we have any other
musicians in the building?
No?
OK.
I'm sure we do, but yeah.
All right.
Check this out.
Let me see.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
All right.
[SINGING] Hey.
Hey.
[GUITAR LOOP CONTINUES]
OK.
[BEATBOXING]
[BEATBOXING AND GUITAR LOOPS
CONTINUE]
All right.
Can you can still hear me?
All right, so now we've
got some music, right?
Oh, oh yeah, wait a minute.
[TURNS MUSIC OFF]
OK.
So now we need to put
together the hook.
This is communal music, so
we get to do it together.
N-O-W, what's that spell?
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Wow, that was weak.
That was so weak that it
sounded more like meow.
Like, what was that?
Like, what led to that?
But you all did it in unison.
Is that how you talk in
meetings, in whispers like
that?
That was crazy.
All right.
So don't let the
guitar fool you.
This is hip-hop.
So you have to bring a little
bit more energy, a little bit
more oomph to it.
So N-O-W, what's that spell?
AUDIENCE: Now!
SAULPAUL: There we go.
OK, every time I point
to you, you say--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: All right, perfect.
This is how the hook
to the song goes.
If your mind's right,
then you shine right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: You tight right--
SAULPAUL: You bright right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Hey, if your mind
right, it go down right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
Now, now, now, now.
SAULPAUL: To be honest,
due to the lack of melanin
in the room, I didn't really
know about that last part.
I was like, man, this
could get chaotic.
But y'all were on point,
so give yourselves a hand.
Give yourselves a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So here we go.
So now we got the hook, right?
So I'm gonna play the music.
We'll do the hook together.
And then I'm going
to make up a song.
I'm going to freestyle, right?
Improvisationally make up a song
on the spot using these words.
Every time I use
one of these words,
this is what I need you to do.
I need you to chunk the deuce.
Anybody from Houston?
AUDIENCE: Me.
SAULPAUL: I love it,
I love it, I love it.
I had it, right?
What happened to my--
SAULPAUL: Towel.
I got a towel.
OK, It's all good.
I was looking for this--
it was a white towel.
Anybody seen a white towel?
AUDIENCE: Right here.
SAULPAUL: All right, perfect.
Thank you, ma'am.
I get excited when I
perform, and then I perspire.
Like, I love it.
All right, so check it out.
I'm from Houston.
In Houston, we have this thing
called chunking the deuce.
My motto is, "No audience
member left behind."
So even if you don't know how to
chunk the deuce, I've got you.
I'll teach you.
This is my
deuce-chunking tutorial.
Everybody put your
peace sign up.
All right.
Now turn your hand
backwards facing you.
You're gonna love this
if you like math like me.
Bend your wrist 90 degrees.
Go back where you started.
Repeat.
[LAUGHTER]
That's how you chunk the deuce.
All right.
As soon as you leave,
get back on the elevator,
go back to your spot,
just chunk a deuce.
They'll know what's up.
Shoutout to my people from the
H that already knew what was up.
All right.
You can personalize it.
You can go high with it.
You can go low like
it's a silent auction.
You can do two at the
same time, synchronize.
However you want to do it.
This is what I need you
to do because me and Kate,
we're over here working.
We're doing what we do.
Every time I use one of these
words, you chunk the deuce.
That lets Kate know,
like, oh snap, he
must've used one of the words.
And then she deletes it.
So if I'm rapping, and I
say "sky," what do you do?
Oh, I like how she does it.
She's like, yo.
Like, waiter, over here.
Yeah.
I like that.
Swag.
I love it.
If I'm rapping, and I say,
"apple," what do you do?
OK.
Wednesday.
What else do we got?
Taco, not to be confused with
taco salad, but taco and salad.
We got sprint, happy,
antidisestablishmentarianism.
Wow.
And then that other word.
All right.
All right, so here we go.
We're about to
put this together.
And you remember your
part to the hook, right?
All right, cool.
Let me secure my guitar.
Right now, all right.
Let's work.
[RAPPING] If your mind
right, then you shine right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: You tight right--
SAULPAUL: You bright right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Hey.
If your mind right, it go down
right now, now, now, now, now.
One more time.
If your mind right,
then you shine right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: You tight right--
SAULPAUL: You bright right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Hey.
If your mind right, it go down
right now, now, now, now, now.
I speak in slang.
They usually say
it, what him say.
I don't know, but dubs
up, yes, it's Wednesday.
I'm at Google, and I
ain't eating apples.
If it's competition, then
Google defeating Apple.
Man, y'all should've clapped,
but I don't know what's up
right now.
You're all just like,
what's up with that?
OK.
Regardless, I'm gonna
eat the beat like tacos.
Got a lot of bravo
because I'm macho.
I go hard.
Yeah, I'm about the sky up.
I'm going in every
time, yes, I'm up.
An entrepreneur,
entrepreneurialship.
First word he said,
it wasn't a word.
I'm booing it.
I'm moving it.
I'm eating salad.
I'm trying to stay
fit, keep my balance.
I used to go running,
catch me all on the lake.
I'm going hard, welcome my
faith, the opposite of fake.
Hey, if your mind right,
then you shine right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: You tight right--
SAULPAUL: You bright right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Hey, if
your mind right,
it go down right now,
now, now, now, now.
One more time.
Hey, if your mind right,
then you shine right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: You tight right--
SAULPAUL: You bright right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Hey, if
your mind right,
it go down right now,
now, now, now, now.
I'm feeling fresh,
about the mint.
I got a different type of
phone, it's not Sprint.
I keep it moving.
They say that I'm loco.
But check out my calendar.
Homie, I'm global.
I care less.
They only T-Mobile.
I'm trying to connect the
dots like AT&T, I'm loco.
That's what that is, loco,
yeah, that mean crazy.
I'm going to get in 'cause
your boy is not lazy.
I'm taking words.
I take them.
I flip them.
I get them.
I twist them.
Say it, I'm not missing.
This last word a long one,
how I'm going to fit in.
Antidisestablishmentarianism.
Hey.
But still, I had to do that.
H-town, we're chunking deuces.
That's where they bump screw at.
I do that.
Yeah, I'm going to throw this.
Supercalifragilisticexpialidocious.
[CHEERING]
Woo.
Hold up.
One more time, one more time.
I like the hook.
Let's just do it one more time.
Hey.
If your mind right,
then you shine right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: You tight right--
SAULPAUL: You bright right--
AUDIENCE: Now.
SAULPAUL: Hey.
If your mind right, it go down
right now, now, now, now, now.
[CHEERING]
All right.
So today, I didn't
really come to perform,
even though I'm going to
do a couple more songs.
Today, I just came to talk a
little bit, share my story.
So we'll consider
that the ice-breaker.
So now that the ice is broken,
I can tell you this story.
I'll tell you all a
little bit about my story.
But I also just want to
tell you about this movement
that I'm proud to be
a part of and part
to be like kindling the flame on
so that we can get it to burn,
and ultimately it's
to change the world.
I've always been a big dreamer.
That's just what I was,
even though I grew up
in a bad environment.
Like I already told
you, I'm from Houston.
I grew up in the ghetto.
My mom died when I
was three years old.
My dad, he ran off and left.
I've never met him in my life.
But I had an
awesome grandmother.
My grandmother, she adopted me.
She took me.
She raised me as her own.
Everybody else called
her grandmother.
They called her Big Mama.
I just called her mama.
She was awesome.
The problem was, she was
old, and I was young.
She was slow, and I was fast.
She was soft-hearted,
and I was hard-headed.
So I grew up in
this environment.
Like I said, one of
the worst ghettos.
I make it look good, and I
think it's hard for people
to really get it
because, you know,
I look so good and what-not.
But I really, really grew
up like in the bottom,
in the trap.
They made a movie about my life.
It's called "Tower to Tower."
If you go to my website,
saulpaul.com, you can see it..
It's like reviewed I
don't know how many times.
It's a big idea.
It's cool.
But it's my story.
It goes more in depth.
But again, I grew up on
the north side of Houston
in the ghetto.
My grandmother adopted me.
She raised me.
She did the best, but I
still made the worst choices.
And it was interesting because
I was always in this paradox.
Like, I'm in the ghetto, but
I'm in the AP courses in school.
I'm in gifted and talented
classes and what-not, right?
And then so I was
always in two worlds.
It helps me now because
I'm cross-cultural.
I have this cultural
competency because I
know how to deal with people
and deal with people there.
But I was still feeling
it out when I was younger.
So I would be in class, my
AP and my gifted and talented
courses when I was in school.
But then when I would
get out of class,
and I'd be around my
friends on the block.
When I was around my
friends on the block,
I just kept my life separate.
One time they collided.
My grandmother, even
thought I grew up poor,
she always spoiled me.
I would always have the
latest video games, the latest
sneakers.
So my friends would come to
my house and play video games.
When they come to
my crib one time,
my grandmother was
so proud of me,
she would put my report
card on the wall.
So my friends come in the
house to play my video games,
and then they would
see my report card.
And then they would
say stuff like, aw.
This fool's stupid.
He made all A's, right?
That doesn't even make sense.
Like, half of it
don't even compute.
I don't understand.
But it was like because
it was a culture clash.
I was making good grades.
That wasn't cool to them.
So that's why I kept it hidden.
But it was interesting because,
again, my culture, society
was teaching me something.
Because I'm in my-- when I was
16 years old, I got arrested.
I got arrested in
my high school.
I went to a big 5A high
school, 2,000, 2,500 students.
I get arrested.
I go to jail.
I come back.
When I come back, in
my ghetto, in my hood,
like do y'all think people
made fun of me because I got
arrested or they showed me love?
AUDIENCE: Love.
SAULPAUL: That's very
unique right there, right?
And it's something that I can
look back in hindsight, 20/20,
and I see like this
contrast, like that's weird.
Like I made good grades,
and people made fun of me.
I got arrested, and I
was like the hood hero.
And I was just a kid
like everybody else.
I just wanted to be accepted.
So instead of focusing
on making good grades,
I focused on being bad.
I actually became the
best at being the worst.
This is what life was
already teaching me.
And it's interesting because
you might say, OK, well,
I was 16 years old
when I got arrested.
When I get arrested,
like example, maybe you
can't relate, but
I bet you still
know the answer
to this question.
Why do people sell drugs?
To make money.
It's that simple, right?
It doesn't matter
if you're like,
well, I want to buy
my baby diapers,
or I just want to
get a new necklace.
The goal is, they just
want to make money, right?
So I figured this out.
I was always an A to Z thinker.
The problem was I wasn't worried
about the steps in between.
So I'm like, well,
people sell drugs
because they want to make money.
So if you asked, well, SaulPaul,
why did you get arrested?
And it was because
I made money, right?
And I got arrested
by the FBI at that.
16 years old, I get
arrested by the FBI.
But it's because I
was making money.
But you said, but
that's not illegal.
I mean, it is if
you like make money.
OK.
All right.
I can't speak on it too much.
But yeah, I used to make money.
But that's a federal offense.
And that's why I got arrested.
It's funny because again,
hindsight, I look back,
and it was like, man.
I remember one time
somebody called me
a criminal genius,
one of my mentors.
And he was like, man, you were
like, think different, dude.
It's like-- I don't know.
I just think how I think.
But that's why I'm so
passionate about mentorship.
I didn't really have
anybody to mentor me.
There are no excuses.
My grandmother showed
me unconditional love.
People would always try
to communicate and tell me
the best.
But again, that's why
I'm passionate about what
I do, because I recognize
just because you tell somebody
the right thing, if you're
not speaking their language,
it doesn't really matter.
And so a lot of people were
telling me the right stuff,
but they weren't
speaking my language.
And that's cool, right?
I travel internationally.
I recognize sometimes, if
you're talking to somebody,
and they don't
speak your language,
then you just get a translator.
It's not even on you to
learn a new language.
I can go to a new country
and not speak the language.
I just get a translator.
That's why I've created a
mentorship program, because I
know the translators, the
people that speak the language.
Because my heart goes out to
these youths that were like me.
But at this point, I
didn't have a mentor.
I didn't have a translator.
I wouldn't listen to anybody
that was telling me anything.
I became the best
at being the worst.
When I was 17 years old,
my grandmother passed away.
Then I feel like it's
me against the world.
I feel like it's only me, right?
So my mom died.
My dad left.
I'm in the ghetto.
The one person that
loved me passed away.
My grandmother now-- it's
just like, it's just me.
And so I'm going
against the grain.
I still graduated high
school, top of my class,
and got an academic scholarship.
So I get an academic
scholarship.
That was the first
time I came to UT.
And you've got to imagine
a little black boy
from the ghetto gets
an academic scholarship
and gets to go to UT.
And it was like, I
felt like Scarface.
It was like, king
of the world, baby.
Then they did something stupid--
like super crazy stupid.
They gave me all my scholarship
money in this one big check
and said, here, this is yours.
I thought I was rich.
Like, wow.
I went and cashed it.
I was waiting for somebody
to try to come arrest me,
and they never did.
And it was like, wow.
And then I went shopping.
And then like two months
later, I got bills in the mail
from the dormitory.
Like, where's your rent?
Oh, that's what
that money was for.
I didn't know.
In addition, right--
and that's key.
I talk about it now.
But it really was like
a lack of life skills.
I recognized I had
all this potential,
but I didn't have a mentor.
I didn't have life skills.
So the program
that I've created,
ReRoute, that's
what we deal with.
We deal with youth
in general, not even
the ones that have potential.
Because the truth is,
everybody has potential.
That's just the truth.
Everybody has
potential, but they
have to figure out what it is,
where theirs is, how to tap it,
and how to polish it.
I didn't.
I was just barreling ahead.
Long story short, it
took three semesters--
I'm all the way to college.
I made it all the way to UT
on an academic scholarship
and never studied in my life.
Some of you probably
can relate to that
because we're all gifted.
We're all gifted
in different areas.
LeBron James, anybody know
what college he went to?
He didn't go to college
because he's that gifted.
But he polished a gift.
You know what I mean?
He'd been playing
basketball like 12,
13 years by the time he was 18.
So it's like, you can be gifted.
I'm sure many of you are gifted.
That's why you get to work here.
That's why you get to work
at a great organization.
That's why people that are
great and do what they do-- I
know a lot of great people.
I get to meet the most
fascinating people.
And it's so funny because I
realize that they're gifted.
And they're gifted in their
area, and they do what they do,
whether that's business, whether
that's finance, whether that's
sports, whether that's
art, whether that's music.
But me, I didn't realize it.
I just got all the
way to college,
and I was like, why
should I study now?
I made it this far.
That didn't make sense.
I guess they've got
to study, not me.
But that didn't work.
It took three semesters before
I flunked out of school.
I lost my academic scholarship.
I got put on
scholastic probation.
I was a victim to myself,
really, a victim to pride.
I was a victim to
like, well, everybody
knew me as being the dude who
always had the latest sneakers.
I had the biggest necklaces.
I had the nicest car.
I did this and did that.
And I was living irresponsibly.
So now it was like, I have
to keep up this facade,
but now I don't have any
more scholarship money
to spend on it.
So I resorted to what I knew.
So I went back to hustling.
So I go back to
hustling, and I was
doing all the stuff
that was I doing.
I got convicted of
three more felonies.
Add that to the
one I already had.
That made four, and they
sent me to the Texas State
Penitentiary.
So now I get kicked
out of UT, and I end up
at the Texas Department
of Corrections, TDC.
TDCJ.
So I'm sitting in
prison, and it's
crazy to just go
from the opulence
that they had at
UT to just being
a number in prison, 758371.
And they no longer
called me by my name.
They just called me 758371.
And I'm sitting in prison.
And for me, that was
an eye-opening moment,
because at that
moment, I realized
that it wasn't my circumstances,
but it was my choices.
It wasn't because I was black.
It wasn't because I
grew up in the ghetto.
It wasn't my mom
died and my dad left.
It wasn't the system.
You all ever heard of the Man?
People say, like, it's the Man.
Like apparently there's some
dude out there called the Man.
And if I ever run
into him, I'm going
to come up because
he owes me something.
But that's not why
I was locked up.
I was locked up because
I made bad choices.
But that was empowering
because I realized
if you make bad choices
and you get bad results,
if you make better choices,
you get better results.
So I'm going to pause.
I'm going to do a song.
I'll pause.
I'll do a song, and then
I'll finish telling you
how the story goes, right?
But this is what I realized
when I was incarcerated.
I realized that my mama, my
grandmother that raised me,
she had a vision for my life.
And that unconditional
love that she showed me,
it laid a foundation for me.
And really, she just
wanted me to be successful.
I think that's why
she just showed me
that-- I understand
the power of love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I recently debuted this
song in New York City,
just a few weeks ago
for Mother's Day.
I did this event in partnership
with the UN Foundation
and Johnson & Johnson
because they had this event.
It was called Moms +SocialGood,
where they honored moms.
I believe teachers and moms
are some of the most unsung
heroes in the world.
They do the most, and
they get the least.
But I wrote this song.
Check it out.
It goes--
[SINGING] Mama, mama, I'ma
be everything you saw in me.
Yeah.
True, you are gone.
Don't get it confused,
this is not a sad song.
I've been shining
oh so bright simply
'cause you raised me right.
Yeah, and gave me so much game.
I'ma man show the whole
world singing now.
P-E-A-R-L-I-E, I call her Ms.
Collins, may she rest in peace.
See, she be why I be me,.
Momma raised a monster and
left the world with a beast.
Hey.
No mama, no daddy,
no bro, no sis.
I grew up an only child,
man, just me and this chick.
Some called her Big Mama,
some called her Miss.
I call her the only reason
I could have all this.
She gave me the game and
she laid the foundation.
Now I done took that thing
and founded a nation.
She told me never follow.
Be a leader.
She's why I know Christ,
why I'm a believer.
People say SaulPaul,
what's your secret?
I just laced you, let those
that have ears peep it, see it,
could not be made no plainer.
I put that on what I
love with no disclaimer.
P-E-A-R-L-I-E. I call her Ms.
Collins, may she rest in peace.
See, she be why I be me.
Momma raised a monster,
left the world with a beast.
Mama, mama, I'ma be
everything you saw in me.
Yeah.
True, you are gone.
Don't get it confused,
this is not a sad song.
I've been shining
oh so bright simply
'cause you raised me right.
Yeah, and you gave
me so much game,
I'ma man show the whole world,
singing that P-E-A-R-L-I-E,
I call her Ms. Collins,
may she rest in peace.
See, she be why I be me.
Momma raised a monster,
left the world with a beast.
Hey, I grew a poet
and I ain't even
know it 'cause when we let
go, she didn't even show it.
She kept me focused,
head in them textbooks.
Now I'm living good.
Look how them checks look.
She taught me about love.
She taught me about life.
Showed me what was wrong and
taught me what was right.
Then she let me live me
life, but I made mistakes.
She still showed me love, so
I guess she taught me grace.
She taught me about
faith and family,
and home should be your place
of peace even in a calamity.
She told me straight, this world
is insanity, but once I make it
out the hood, oh,
what a man I'll be.
Well, I made it, Mama.
Wish you could see me now.
I got the world watching 'cause
I'm straight gleaming now.
I did good.
It's 'cause she did better.
This is not a song.
It's a love letter.
Mama, mama, I'ma be
everything you saw in me.
Yeah.
True, you are gone.
Don't get it confused,
this is not a sad song.
I've been shining
oh so bright simply
'cause you raised me right.
Yeah, and you gave
me so much game,
I'm a man show the whole world,
singing that P-E-A-R-L-I-E,
I call her Ms. Collins,
may she rest in peace.
See, she be why I be me.
Momma raised a monster,
left the world with a beast.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So the way that the
story ends, right,
so I can move on to another
song in a second, what ended up
happening was, I was in prison.
And I realized,
again, like I said,
it was my choices,
not my circumstance.
That empowered me.
When I was in prison,
I started dreaming big,
and that's what changed the
game to like this moment now.
Because like I said in the song,
right, that's not a sad song.
Like my grandmother,
she laid a foundation,
she put a lot into me.
She lived her life as
a sacrifice for me.
And because of that, I'm
doing pretty good right now.
I ended up-- I
had four felonies.
I had 10 years that I was in
the Texas State Penitentiary.
In Texas, when you get 10
years, you know how long you do?
10 years.
I was there for like two.
I was a modern-day miracle.
I get out of prison.
I'm on parole.
I get out of the Texas State
Penitentiary on parole,
and I get re-admitted to the
prestigious University of Texas
at Austin.
Not only would I get back
into the University of Texas
at Austin, this time around
I'm not taking it for granted,
because I'm actually
doing my work.
That's why I ended up doing
better when I graduated.
But deeper still, I
figured out something.
And I figured out that I was
born on purpose with a purpose.
And I quit taking life light.
I quit taking it for granted.
And it was like, OK, cool.
So what's my purpose?
And I realized, I
want to touch people.
And I want to do
it through media.
I want to do it through movies.
I want to do it through
mobile gaming apps.
I want to do it through music.
I want to do it through
live presentations.
I want to put together creative
productions and touch people
and inspire people.
That's what I decided
I wanted to do.
And at this point, you all
probably don't know it.
Some of you all might.
I don't know how old you are.
But there's this network.
It's called MTV.
Back in the day, they
used to show music videos.
Not anymore.
But they used to
show music videos.
So I used to just watch
all these music videos.
And it was like, man, I just
want to make music videos.
But was like, you can't
go to college for that.
Little did I know, I was
talking to my academic advisor,
and he was like, man, a music
video's just like a mini-movie.
You should get into
the film school.
And I was like, that's
what I want to do.
He was like, yeah,
the film school's one
of the best in the country.
Are you sure that's
what you want to do?
And I set my sight on that.
And I got accepted
to the film school
at UT, one of the
best in the country.
Long story short, I graduated
from the film school
with a 4.0.
So I go from four
felonies to a 4.0.
And at this point,
when I graduated,
my first project was
called "Tower to Tower."
Because I was at the UT tower.
I remember it was May 17.
I'm sitting at the tower.
I got on my cap and gown.
I got a few relatives, a few
family members, a few people
from the block.
You know what I'm saying?
It was amazing to see the
love and feel the support.
They all came from Houston.
They're in a big crowd.
They're sitting there.
I got on the cap and gown.
And I'm sitting there, and
they're doing the speech.
I'm waiting for them to call my
name and all that good stuff.
And I'm sitting there, and it's
like, I don't know, 5:00, 6:00,
and we're at the tower.
And the sun's setting.
And I'm sitting at the tower,
and I'm looking at the tower,
and it clicks.
Like, wow, I went
from tower to tower.
Because you know,
in prison, they
have the watch
guard tower, right?
That's like where the
dude has the rifle,
and they're waiting for somebody
to run so they can shoot.
Because I used to be sitting
in my penitentiary cell looking
through the Plexiglas
window past the barbed wire,
and I would see that tower.
And I would dream
about when I get out.
And here I was at UT
about to graduate,
moments from graduation,
and I see the UT tower.
And it was like, wow.
I went from tower to tower.
And see that right there, that
was kind of like when-- that's
when they create-- even
in the song, I say,
"Momma raised a monster and
left the world with a beast."
That's when I realized,
oh, I got a problem.
Like, wow, it's OK to dream.
A lot of people don't dream.
I'm going to assume you
are dreamers because Google
is like this
awesome company that
does great things
and profound things.
And I run a company myself.
And so I recognize
that there's a culture.
And we created a
culture in my company.
And so I'm going to assume that
there's an awesome culture here
as well.
And I know that many times,
though, the culture-- culture
in life, like in general,
doesn't promote dreaming.
It doesn't promote
dreaming big, thinking big,
having a huge vision.
At that point, though,
that's when something clicks.
Because it was like, wow,
I was in the penitentiary.
And I dreamed about
going back to college.
When I told people
who were in prison,
like, dude, this for the birds.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm never coming back here.
They literally laughed at
me like that was crazy.
That's a whole different speech
for a different audience.
This is Google.
I have a lot of respect for
you, you know what I'm saying?
But it's crazy because
just yesterday,
I was at an elementary school.
The crowd was a lot more crunk.
And it was bigger.
But no, it's all good.
I like you still.
But when I'm at an elementary
school or a high school,
like when I told you
I was in New York,
I was at this other event.
Or I'm going to stay--
I'm in a penitentiary.
I'm in a juvenile
detention center one day.
I'm in a penitentiary the next.
Because I don't see people
as these demographics
and different types.
They're just people.
And I know because
it was me, right?
So I can be here,
and I'm a person.
But I was also in
the penitentiary.
And when I was in
the penitentiary,
I was the same person.
I was just living
out my choices.
But when I'm talking
to somebody in prison,
it's crazy because I'm
trying to get them to dream.
Because when I was in
prison, I told people,
I'm going to get out, and
I'm going to go to college,
and I'm going to graduate, and
they straight-up laughed at me.
They would literally call
people over, like, hey, hey,
come over here and
check this out.
Say, tell him what you told us.
Like, literally.
It was crazy.
Like, bro, I'm never
coming back to prison.
And they were like,
that's crazy, man.
How are you going to say
what you're going to do?
I remember them
clearly saying that.
And that hurt me, not
that they didn't believe,
but where their mind was.
Like, wow, you're
such a victim of life
that you really
don't feel like you
have control of what
your life will be.
They're like, you can't
say whether or not
you're going to
come back to prison.
You can't say what
you're going to do.
But you can say what
You can dream.
You can speak it.
And then you can put in
the work to make it happen.
And I love it because
I keep doing it.
But that's not a
prison mentality.
Sadly, that's a human mentality.
There's so many people
that feel trapped, right?
People go to prison,
people feeling trapped.
And so me, my goal is to unleash
people, to release people,
to maybe touch something
inside and say, man,
if it was me-- because
it's not about just me.
It's like, cool, so
I'll tell you my story,
but this is-- I'm a case study.
I'm just a walking, talking
case study, like, look at me.
I had no help, no
resources, no support,
but it's not because look at me.
It's more like, I mean,
if I did it, why not you?
I remember during
Christmas break,
or even summer break, everybody
else would get excited,
like, man, we get to go
home, we get to go do this.
And I'm like, I
don't know where I'm
going to stay because
the dorm closes,
and they don't open up
for like three weeks,
and I don't have
a home to go to.
But anyway, so where I'm at now.
When I graduated, I started
working at a television
station, an ABC
affiliate here in Austin.
Or in Austin, Texas.
And so I started working
at that television station.
I worked there for a year.
It was cool.
But that's when I
started dreaming, like,
man, I want to create a company.
I want to build a company.
I want to make music.
I want to make movies.
I want to make video games.
I want to make a difference.
And so I worked there for a
year, and then I resigned.
Then I started my company,
ReRoute Productions.
At the same time, I started
the nonprofit ReRoute.
And it's interesting
because when
you work with wires,
anything technical,
like you reroute the wires.
Like it might not be
working, so you reroute it.
That's where it came from.
But at the same time, when
it came to the outreach,
it was more about
like rerouting lives.
Because there were
so many people that
have felt like there were so
many people that were lost,
and it was like-- it goes
back to what I talked about
in the beginning, just
having the right translators.
I realize, cool,
I'm a translator.
But there are so many.
So what I do is I work with--
I do a lot of consulting now
for large brands and
companies and people that
have corporate responsibility
divisions and arms,
and they want to reach people,
and I help them do it better.
I'm that translator.
And I bring in other
people that are translators
and help them create systems
and organizations that
create the most.
We did this very, very
cool event during South
by Southwest.
I'm sure you all are probably
familiar with the Spotify
House.
Green House, Sixth Street,
South By, it's the place to be.
For the first year, they did
this outreach to the community.
And so I was a part of
that, and it was awesome.
It was great.
And we got to impact
some students that
were there in Austin
for the event.
That's just one example.
I'm going to do another song.
I have this new project
that's called Dream in 3D.
This is the song
from that project.
It's called "Rise."
This is what I want to
inspire people to do.
Let's see.
And so I have a book.
I have a book.
The book is called
"Dream in 3D."
I have a mobile gaming app.
The mobile gaming app is called
"SaulPaul-- Dream in 3D."
And it's cool because you can
play it on your Google device.
Anybody ever play "Temple Run"?
Yeah?
It's like an endless runner?
All right.
So the mobile gaming app is
kind of like "Temple Run,"
except it's in the hood.
[LAUGHTER]
So if you're into these
songs, and you're like, oh,
that music's sweet, you can go
download it, Google Play store
and other places.
I don't even know why that
was funny, but it's funny.
People always say, you're funny.
I'm like, I'm not trying
to be, so you must just
be laughing at me.
All right.
But-- and I have this book.
So this is the lyrics to the
song that I'm about to sing.
But the book is actually
like the annotated lyrics.
So it's pretty cool.
You should go check it out,
tell somebody about it.
All right.
Here goes the song.
Just check it out.
Like this.
[SINGING] Rise, rise,
and open your eyes.
Now is the time for
you to shine, yeah.
Say rise, rise,
and open your eyes.
Now is the time for
you to shine, yeah.
[RAPPING] Rise to the
moment, rise to the occasion.
Open your eyes, recognize there
is greatness within your reach.
You should seize it,
you should take it.
Can you see it?
Can you take destiny?
Hard work and a plan, now
that's a recipe for success
that'll launch you
where them blessings be.
The road to riches, though,
that's where them tests be.
But I ain't tripping, you
knowing how us Texans be.
A lot of pride, plus a lot
of confidence, and my job
is to see what is not obvious,
as a pioneer, an entrepreneur.
So I'm gonna work it out 'til
it's smoother than velour.
For sure, I'ma gonna make
it to that finish line.
I got my second wind,
and now it's finish time.
It's like spinach
time, and I am Popeye.
Stop short?
No, not I.
[SINGING] Rise, rise,
and open your eyes.
Now is the time for
you to shine, yeah.
Say rise, rise,
and open your eyes.
Now is the time for
you to shine, yeah.
[RAPPING] Hey.
You got nothing to lose.
What'll make you deadly, play
like you got nothing to prove.
Don't be fronting for fools.
Stay focused.
You got something to do.
Snatch the top slot.
What's the use in number two?
Hold your own like Neo
when they come for you.
You choose to rule or
chopped like lumber do.
The comfort of slumber keep
the dumb ones under the roof.
Those scared of thunder die as
they hide but hunger for food.
You was birthed on this Earth
with a purpose and call.
Does it blow your mind to find
it's more than simply serving
the Lord?
Every day that you wake,
you're involved in a war.
Recall when you swore it'd
never get as worse as before?
Better take what's yours,
or they'll take what yours.
From this day forward, be great,
change your fate for sure.
Let the hate elevate the
rate at which you score.
Time is ticking much quicker.
You can't wait no more.
[SINGING] Rise, rise,
and open your eyes.
Now is the time for
you to shine, yeah.
I said, rise, rise,
and open your eyes.
Now is the time for you to
shine, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So yeah.
Just a little bit
about my organization.
This summer is very, very cool.
I just partnered with
the UN Foundation,
and we're about to go on-- I'm
going on a big summer tour.
I'll be playing some major
festivals like the Orange
County Fair, you know what
I'm saying, in Orange County.
I'll play the world's
largest music festival
in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin, Summerfest.
And then I'll play like
Safeway Barbecue Battle in DC,
as well as Music
Fest in Philadelphia,
this other festival
in Minnesota,
the Sunshine Festival, as
well as the Cutting Edge Music
Festival in New Orleans.
So I'll get to be in front
of over a million people
this summer.
It's not even just like
a normal little set.
But I get to go even
be an ambassador
for the city of Austin.
I was just named an ambassador
Actually on June 12
in Austin, they're
naming June 12 SaulPaul Day.
So I've been to City Hall.
That's like a huge contrast
right there, right?
I'm trying to figure out--
I get to make one rule.
I don't know what it
is, but it'll probably
be related to barbecue.
I'm working on it.
So very many, many cool
things are happening.
But I've been plotting, and
I've been thinking, like man,
how can I use this
platform of being able--
like all these platforms
to be able to leverage
it to create some
type of change?
And my goal really
is in the next year
to touch 10 million people.
Like I get to see a
million just this summer.
But it's also to incorporate
social media into that.
And just because
there's power in story.
There's power in story.
Like I tell my story,
and it touches people.
But I'm not foolish.
It's not just my story.
I've been inspired by people.
I remember when I was in
prison, and I would read books
about people that I
still have yet to meet.
I would just read
their book, and it
was like-- it
changed my worldview.
It made me different.
I'll see a tweet,
and it'll change.
I'll be in a Google Hangout,
and somebody will say something,
and it's like, wow, I'm going
to steal that and tweet that.
And it's powerful
what we can do.
And so you should
follow up with me,
get with me at saulpaul.com.
That's my headquarters.
If you go to saulpaul.com,
you can find everything
that I've mentioned,
like the mobile gaming
app, the book, the
music, tour calendar.
No matter what it is,
you can find it there.
And I would love to
connect because I
know that you have
greatness inside of you,
and if nothing
else, you might be
able to help mentor some of
the youth that I'm exposed to.
Because it's pretty crazy.
I feel like the Pied Piper.
I go do what I do,
and then these kids
are like, man, that's what's up.
And then they go to the
website, and they're there.
And it's this online community.
But my goal is to connect
them with other people
because I can't
do it all myself.
I can't do it alone.
I don't desire to.
I get to meet the
coolest people that
do the greatest
and coolest things,
and they're like-- then
they'll have an opportunity
to pour into somebody else.
So of you're looking
for an opportunity
to pour into somebody else,
please get in contact with me
because I can hook you up.
I have not enough mentors
and too many kids.
And it's not even deep.
It's not even time.
It can be online.
You can just connect with them.
It's cool.
We have this whole chat
room and everything.
And you can just,
like, wise words.
Because me-- because
I know it works.
That's why I made it
all the way to college.
I never had life
skills or any insight
that anybody could give me.
And that's why I made
those poor choices.
I recognize what I'm special
at is because I didn't give up,
I didn't quit, I
didn't beat myself up.
Instead, I was able
to turn it around.
But I want to help
some other people.
I want to help some
young people before they
make those mistakes.
So I may or may not
do another song,
but I hate one-sided
conversations,
so you all talk to me.
Does anybody have
anything to share, say?
Questions, karaoke?
Yes, ma'am.
NICOLE: Can you follow
up with me briefly?
SAULPAUL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'll
speak to you after.
KATE: Nicole runs our
GoogleServe events here,
and I think she's got some
good stuff in store for you.
NICOLE: Yeah, we could
definitely partner up
with you guys and
donate our skills.
And I'm sure we can get a
couple mentors out of here.
So yeah, I'll talk to you after.
SAULPAUL: OK.
That'd be awesome.
Yeah, that's very, very cool.
It's funny.
Your video technicians, I had a
different conversation on that.
I don't want it to live
forever on the web.
I'll give you a contrast.
I had a meeting at
Nike earlier this year.
It was very, very cool.
There's an awesome guy there
that supports the vision,
and we're working on some
very, very cool stuff.
And it's crazy, right?
Because I was in
Beaverton, Oregon, at Nike.
But when I was young, I used to
do some very, very bad things
just to get Nikes.
So this contrast blows my mind.
I'm like, wow.
And I just see that contrast.
Or I use Johnson & Johnson, like
baby oil, so that I'm not ashy.
But now I'm working
with Johnson & Johnson
and been able to
do some cool stuff.
So my goal is like
kids will ask me
like-- because I
rap, they're like,
what other famous-- like who
do you know that's famous?
I'm like, me.
And then they're like, who
do you collaborate with?
And I tell them the
artists and what-not.
But I'm more concerned
with collaborating
with brands and companies
because I remember
that same reason why I
made counterfeit money.
I'm trying to figure
out how to get
the biggest bang for the effort.
And I realize like to partner
with cool people like you
all, and they've
already vetted you out.
You all are the
best of the best.
So yeah, we'd love that help.
Yes, ma'am, in the back.
AUDIENCE: How [INAUDIBLE]?
SAULPAUL: Oh.
Hold up one second.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
SAULPAUL: No worries.
I'm going to have
to edit this, man.
AUDIENCE: How did you--
SAULPAUL: I'll be halfway
looking crazy all on Google,
dude.
Because it's going to
be the first thing that
pops up anytime they
Google me, right?
And it's going to be like this.
So you've got to edit it down.
AUDIENCE: How did
you learn to play?
Were you self-taught?
And when did you learn to play?
SAULPAUL: That's
a great question.
I'm self-taught.
I had a teacher.
I'm a certified
personal trainer.
And when I used to train--
I don't train anymore.
People can't afford me.
But when I used to
train, I was on campus,
and I remember putting this
sign up, and it was like,
I just discovered this
crazy concept called barter.
And I was like, will barter.
That's like when
you trade stuff.
I'm like, yeah.
I'll be your
personal trainer, you
teach me to play
guitar or piano.
Luckily, somebody answered
it that played guitar,
and they went and
bought this guitar.
Like, we went to the guitar
store, bought this guitar.
At that point, I didn't
have the discipline.
Again, hindsight is 20/20.
Because I'd only show up.
And so I can't give
them any credit
for teaching me because
I didn't do my part.
But later, it clicked,
and I fell in love
with playing this guitar.
And it's interesting
because it made me--
I created my own lane.
It wasn't on purpose
to be different.
It was just like,
I like rapping,
but now I play the guitar.
I want to do both.
And so I put them
together and now do
this acoustic hip-hop thing.
And so it's pretty awesome.
And then I personalize it, put
that percussion style into it.
Do you play?
Do want to play?
AUDIENCE: No.
SAULPAUL: Oh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAULPAUL: Yeah.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Your story is
very inspiring, so I just
want to know, what is your
biggest and proudest moment?
And I have another question.
If you can tell us more about
your collaboration with Johnson
& Johnson.
Because I've seen some
of their commercials
that they made for the
mothers, and I think
those are some of
the most touching
stories in commercials.
So I would be interested
to know more about that.
SAULPAUL: Great question.
My greatest accomplishment
I wouldn't know.
The answer for that
one is recently,
I built a mentorship program.
Yeah.
That's the biggest deal.
Because another thing-- and
you can't get credit for it.
And I tell the artists,
like people only
know artists-- there's
like this huge void.
Like you're either quote
unquote an "aspiring artist,"
"starving artist"--
that's crazy to me--
or you're platinum or 10 times
platinum, and you're rich,
right?
And it's like nobody knows
the artists in between.
So the fact that I can make a
living, like this is what I do,
this is my job, that's amazing.
So that might be like the
greatest accomplishment,
literally to be
like, this is work.
If you see me at work,
I do nothing different.
This is work.
That's amazing to me.
Because there's this big
void in between them,
like I just want
to make a living.
I don't want to be
a starving artist.
But I just want to make
a living as a musician.
I get to do that
and write the songs
that I want to write and touch
the people I want to touch.
But in the process, I
discovered I have this platform.
I see so many people.
And so I went on a tour,
and I came back to Austin.
And when I came back
to Austin, people
were like-- I partnered
with a nonprofit,
and I built a
mentorship program.
I was able to use my
platform to recruit people.
Because artists are
starving, but they're
probably more famous
than most people.
They get platforms to be
in front of more people.
And so I just came up with
this plan to say, like, well,
what if I used my
platform to recruit?
And I ended up building
a mentorship program
for adjudicated youth, youth
that were incarcerated already,
15 years old, 14 years, 17 years
old, and find mentors for them.
And these kids are a
little bit different.
So you can't just--
you don't get
to mentor them and go
fishing on the weekend.
You mentor them, and
you go fishing for them
on the weekend.
But I found the coolest
people, and the relationships
are still long-lasting.
So building that
mentorship program,
I'd probably say that's my
greatest accomplishment.
That's really what opened my
eyes to consulting as well,
like helping brands
and companies
with their corporate
responsibility,
because I personally recruited
more mentors into multimillion
dollar non-profits that
had the same assignment.
And it's just because my
techniques were different
and the platform was different.
And so that's probably my
greatest accomplishment.
What was the other question?
AUDIENCE: Collaboration
with Johnson&Johnson.
SAULPAUL: The collaboration
with Johnson & Johnson.
Oh, I can't speak
on it too much.
We could talk
outside or whatever.
But, again, they're
videotaping me.
And I still have
hood tendencies,
so I don't like
cameras and cops.
So I'll tell you on the side.
Other question?
No, ma'am, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So you
work with tech, and I
know that you're working with
folks who are still in TDCJ,
and you have that intersection.
I don't know what it's like now,
but you know how it used to be.
Folks would go away, and
then they'd come out.
And when you're doing
reentry, technology
is so far beyond you.
SAULPAUL: Oh my goodness.
I did not know what WWW was.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
so much-- and it
affects so much antirecidivism
and that kind of stuff.
Do you all work with--
is it still like that?
And do you all work
with working with folks
with reentry and kind of
catching them up on tech stuff?
SAULPAUL: That is
a great question.
And you just spawned
something with that question.
Yeah, that's still an issue.
That's still an issue.
The questions she's asking is
like, when you go to jail--
and it was crazy,
because technology
is moving like even faster now.
Like 10 years ago, it was crazy.
I remember when I went
to jail and got out,
it was just like what
are these things that
come on commercials
at the bottom?
It was web addresses, right?
And how do you send an email?
How do you do this,
and how do you do that?
And so you just
made a great point.
It does affect recidivism
because when you come out,
it's kind of like
being illiterate,
except you're
computer illiterate.
And then that makes you just do
less, and then the less you do,
the further you fall behind.
And then that kind
of feeds back into,
well, I'll just
go back to what I
know because I can't
even be on par.
So you just spawned
an idea, though.
But yeah, that'd be a great
use of some tech-savvy people
to update some people and update
even young people and adults as
well because it's probably even
worse for the adults, yeah.
AUDIENCE: With your
mentorship program,
what all cities have
you guys touched?
SAULPAUL: Great question.
Austin, Atlanta, Philadelphia,
Newark, New Jersey,
New York City, Washington,
DC, Los Angeles.
I might be forgetting
one or two, but--
AUDIENCE: St. Louis?
SAULPAUL: --those
are the key ones.
Not St. Louis.
Not St. Louis yet.
I have a connection there.
They're waiting
for me to come out,
but I haven't been there yet.
But I've done some stuff with
NSBE, National Society of Black
Engineers, and they're waiting
for us to create something.
Are you from St. Louis?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I'm from the area.
Yeah, St. Louis
definitely needs you.
SAULPAUL: Yeah, we should talk.
It's easy.
It's like, when I made
that song in the beginning,
like no matter what the words
are, I'm able to take a song
and make it.
I suck at basketball.
But I can sing a song,
and I can impact a life.
So I feel like there's
no bottleneck when
it comes to that, especially
since we have a great system.
AUDIENCE: A quick question.
What are you reading right now?
SAULPAUL: "SaulPaul:
Dream in 3D."
[LAUGHTER]
Real talk, like, what are
you listening to right now?
Like, I listen to me.
That's a great question.
What am I reading right now?
What's the last book?
Do you know?
I forget the name of it.
I bought three books in the
last-- I just came off tour.
I've been on tour for
the last three weeks.
And I did not get to
read while I was in tour,
even though I was in
a lot of airports.
Because when I like to
read, I like to read.
I don't like to read
a page and put it up.
I forget, but mainly I
read business books now.
That's a great question.
A great book that I read is
"The Celestine Prophecy."
You ever heard of that one?
Anybody read that book?
That's a very cool book.
"Celestine Prophecy."
And I read the Bible a lot.
That's probably
what I read the most
outside of any other books.
But yeah, I read a
lot of business books.
And it's cool.
And not music business
books, because-- that's
a whole other conversation.
Yeah, business is business.
So yeah, my goal is even--
I didn't elaborate on it,
but my goal to touch a million
people in the next year-- 10
million people, rather-- is
because like in the music
industry, they
quantify everything
by sales, like
sales and downloads.
That's cool, but
I'm trying to-- I'm
grading mine by how many lives
I touch and how to be scalable.
That's why we can go
to St. Louis like that.
Other questions?
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Why not Houston?
SAULPAUL: I forgot that one.
Yeah, Houston.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SAULPAUL: See?
It's kind of like
when you're balling.
When you're balling, it's
funny because it's a big deal
that I remember SaulPaul Day.
I done like I don't
know how many shows,
and then I get offstage,
and my team-- shoutout
to Team ReRoute in the
building-- they'll be like,
you didn't mention this.
And I'm like, oh yeah, I forgot.
I forgot Houston, yeah.
Yeah, we're actually doing some
very cool things in Houston.
I was in Houston two days ago,
and we're building a program,
building up.
Our most extensive mentorship
program yet is in Houston.
And that's starting
this next school yeah.
Yeah, I forgot that.
That's crazy.
And that's it.
That's it for time as well.
I don't want to-- yeah.
KATE: Thank you--
[APPLAUSE]
KATE: --oh so, so much, man.
That was awesome.
Thank you so much.